vous lisiez l'actualité c'est la réforme
de retraite et la mobilisation contre
cette réforme et elle a fait le plein
hier avec un à deux millions de
manifestants dans toute la France
notamment à Bordeaux et à Tours tours
d'horizon et en reparle
si tu savais
ta réponse c'est sous une pluie battante
que l'imposant cortège est parti à midi
de la place de la République pour une
boucle à travers la ville
donc c'est un boulot qui est quand même
très physique et
déjà à partir de l'âge de 60 ans je suis
pas persuadé déjà de pouvoir continuer à
creuser pour moi on se voit pour
l'ensemble en fait du monde du travail
et c'est vrai que nous au niveau de la
blanchisserie on a une carrière d'être
pénible donc normalement on peut
prétendre à partir à la retraite à 57
ans et là ça va nous faire reculer à 50
moments
la mobilisation se déroule dans le calme
et beaucoup sont là pour soutenir le
mouvement de faire des études pour leur
dire qu'il y a pas d'avenir je comprends
pas dire à des enfants d'aller apprendre
un métier s'ils ont malheureusement pas
la possibilité de faire des études pour
qu'il n'ait pas d'avenir je comprends
pas
symbole d'une participation que les
syndicats considèrent historiques la
manifestation tout range elle contre la
réforme des retraites à traverser la
Loire et dans les deux sens entre 12000
et 15000 personnes se sont mobilisées
pour maintenir la retraite à 62 ans le
diagnostic il manque des sous certes
pourquoi pas on peut entendre qui manque
des sous sauf que la solution n'est pas
d'accord faire travailler tout le monde
2 ans de plus voire plus longtemps pour
pour certains salariés c'est pas
acceptable de l'argent il y a d'autres
moyens d'en trouver on fait des baisses
d'impôts on fait des alliments de charge
pour les entreprises donc l'argent il
existe dans le cortège des salariés du
public du privé une manifestation
interprofessionnelle et
intergénérationnelle les représentants
des syndicats sont contents c'est un
message qu'on envoie aussi au
gouvernement de dire cette retraite elle
est pas elle ne rencontre pas l'adhésion
des Français en Loir-et-Cher la
mobilisation a été très massive aussi
avec 8500 manifestants sur ces images à
Blois 1200 à Romorantin et 1200 avant
dôme
et oui ils étaient nombreux vous étiez
vous-même dans le cortège hier
à Paris satisfait de cette mobilisation
historique c'est une mobilisation parmi
les plus importantes mobilisations
sociales
qui est connu le pays je crois qu'il
faut qu'on remonte à au début des années
2000 pour une première journée aussi
importante et avec alors non seulement 2
millions de personnes chacun comprendra
ce que ça signifie puisque ça signifie
aussi comme légitimité des syndicats
parce qu'on le dit pas assez ça on
savait 93% des actifs étaient contre le
projet mais peut-être que certains
doutaient que les syndicats puissent
mobiliser les syndicats aux couvigent
une sacrée capacité de mobilisation mais
c'est moins dit aussi beaucoup de grève
hier et notamment des grèves dans des
secteurs qui ne se mettaient plus en
grève depuis longtemps je pense à
l'usine Bonduelle qui a fermé par
exemple dans le Nord tellement il y
avait des grévistes donc ça c'est
véritablement une grande réussite c'est
une vague
qui a submergé le pays et je pense que
la prochaine le 31 ça va être une
déferlante et est-ce que vous allez
pouvoir garder la CFDT longtemps avec
vous parce que bon il y a un prochain
rendez-vous le 31 janvier mais hier soir
Laurent Berger a dit on va pas casser la
machine on les voit pas s'embarquer dans
dans des grèves à répétition ça reste un
syndicat réformiste et constructif
j'avoue je parlais pas trop au nom de
Laurent Berger parce que
je vous le conseille mais quand vous
avez 93% d'actifs qui sont contre un
projet quand vous avez 2 millions de
personnes dans la rue
comprenez bien que vous n'avez pas que
les Français les plus radicalisés contre
un projet vous avez tous les Français
qui représentent quasiment toutes les
opinions politiques y compris ce que
vous appelez les gens un peu plus
réformistes voilà c'est bien ça
d'ailleurs qui touche que il y a deux
sujets sur lequel les gouvernements se
cassent souvent la figure qui sont dans
la DN social des Français la sécu et les
retraites et moi je ne crois pas du tout
que Laurent Berger va annonce j'allais
dire je ne sais quelle
voie séparer des autres syndicats je
l'ai rencontré Laurent Berger il y a une
semaine je peux vous dire que lui et les
adhérents de la CFDT ils sont remontés
comme des pendules parce que ils avaient
dit qu'ils ne voulaient pas de ce projet
de recul de l'âge de la retraite et ils
avaient raison et moi je les sens pas du
tout j'allais dire en retrait par
rapport aux autres syndicats donc je
trouve là-dessus je suis pas très
inquiet Rousset les insoumis
co-organisent on va dire ce samedi une
marche en tout cas ce sont joints aux
organisations de jeunesse qui avait
appelé à défiler est-ce que c'est une
stratégie pertinente est-ce risque ces
paquets moins de monde ce samedi
mouvement va décrescendo de personnes
dans la rue mais moi ça le fasse pas une
surprise mais on a dit clairement de
quoi il s'agissait quand vous avez un
mouvementiel de social de ces temples
qui se développe vous avez le fleuve le
fleuve c'est les journées interses comme
hier ça va être le 30 le 31 janvier etc
c'est donc le mouvement syndical le
fleuve et puis vous avez des affluents
qui viennent entretenir la flamme la
manifestation du 21 à l'appel des
organisations de jeunesse c'est un
affluent les meeting que vous organisez
la loupesses un peu partout dans le pays
ce sont des affluents voilà pour
donner des arguments convaincre faire
rentrer des secteurs qui n'étaient pas
encore dans la lutte mais il est clair
que les journées testent hier le test a
été vous plus que ici ce sont les
journées mobilisation décidées par les
syndicats
[Musique]